الابراج في الكتاب علاقه هاري ويليام
علاقه متوتره والسبب في ذلك ميجا بطله
بطله من ابطال مسلسل السوس الشهير في عام
امسك وليم بياقتي
ومزق قلاده وطرحاني على الارض هكذا يتحدث
هاري في كتابه الجديد عن شجار دار مع اخيه
لكن لماذا الشجار ولما كان ينتقد زواج
هاري من مكانها قبل سنه من ذلك وتحديدا
عام 2018 وكان يصفها بالصعبه والفضه
والواقحه الشجرات استمرت بين الاشقاء
الاشقاء ودفعت والدهما عام 2021 بالوقوف
بين هاري وليم طالبا منهما عدم جعل
السنوات الاخيره بالباء الساعه في هذا
الوقت تحديدا عاد هاري الى بريطانيا للمره
الاولى منذ خليه عن دواره بالعائله
الملكيه وذلك من اجل حضور جنازه جدها
الامير فيليب ورغم هذه الخلافات يؤكد هاري
انه ارسل رساله نصيه لوليام يسالها فيها
ان كان سيذهب وزوجته كيتلي قصر فالموريل
حيث كانت الملكه تحتضر هناك لكنه وليم لم
يرد من رضا هو الوالد تشارلز وانت مرحب بك
يا هاري لكنها زوجتك فلا وربما هذا يفسر
اتهام هاري في كتابه للامير تشارلز لانه
يشعر بالغيره من زوجته ليست فقط وانما من
كي- زوجته
اكثر من مليون و400 الف نسخه تم بيعها في
اليوم الاول من اصدار كتاب الامير هاري
الذي طال انتظاره لتصبح النسخه الانجليزيه
منه سبير الاسرع مبيعا في فئه الكتب غير
الروائيه في العالم وتضمن الاصدار الرسمي
للكتاب في العاشر من يناير مع عده مقابلات
التلفزيونيه اعطاها هاري لوسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه والامريطانيه اصاروا الكتاب
سبقته تسريبات من نسخه اسبانيه طرحت في
الاسواق بالخطا وهو ما منح الكتاب فرصه
تسويقا غير متوقعه تحدث هاري عن مشاركته
في قتل خمسه وعشرين عنصر من طالبان ما اثر
ردود فعلا مقلقه اذا شار خبراء في مجال
مكافحه الارهاب الى ان تصريحاته وضعته هو
وافراد عائلته تحت خطر الاستهداف كما تحدث
عن شجار الحاج مع اخيه وليام ولي العهد
الحالي الى جانب اعترافه بتعاطيه
الكوكايين
ثلاثه شباب ووضع هاري والده واخاه في موقف
محرج بعد كشفه عن تفاصيل علاقته المنقطعه
حاليا مع هما في النهايه الخلاصه الاساسيه
التي اجمع عليها كثيرون النهاري امير
المبيعات اعطى الناس اكثر من مكانه يتمنون
معرفته